today on stick to football we have maybe
the greatest football player of all time
Jerry Rice joining us we have the first
quarter of the NFL season is in the
books Connor we're gonna talk a lot
about the race for the number one pick
coaches on the hot seat we're gonna hand
out our awards and of course a ton of
draft on draft questions but as a
lifelong Niners fan Jerry Rice was my
favorite player growing up I'm a little
bit excited today yeah it's gonna be
awesome to talk to Jerry kind of get his
opinion of all these great wide
receivers that play in the NFL today
especially since for so long that it
felt like a B was kind of the
uncontested number one guy in the league
for a few years and that door has been
obviously wide open this year but before
we get to all that let's jump right into
something that is building momentum off
of Monday Night Football that is who the
heck is gonna be picking number one in
this NFL Draft I think back in the
spring we had penciled in the Dolphins
there for a while I know we were really
low in the Bengals really low I don't
know if we were this low we were like
three or four winds kind of low and
Washington Arizona we were very low on
veut but the point is this is not a
one-man race this has become very
interesting what are your thoughts of
this pool of all these teams in the mix
right now we have six winless teams
right now yes and Jets yeah it's it's
unbelievable I I will say I was not
expecting the Broncos to be this bad I
also didn't think that they would be
this bad on defense like you thought
bringing it Vic Fangio that's where they
would be strong they've really struggled
to get to the quarterback they lost a
heartbreaker to the Jags this week so
the Broncos and Jess being one list is a
little bit of a surprise to me but when
I look at this if I'm a Dolphins fan I'm
panicking a little bit this morning
because you have all these teams that
you're taking you are actually trying to
lose football games and the Bengals
might look worse than the Dolphins you
know the Broncos have been terrible the
Jets and I know Sam dartle has been hurt
but they look awful as well their
weapons aren't getting any better the
Cardinals Kliff Kingsbury looks in over
his head as well so there are six teams
right now vying for that number one
I'll pick and if you're the Dolphins
you've backed yourselves into this
corner and said we're gonna lose we're
gonna lose we're gonna lose you might
not get the number one pick right now so
I think you have to be a little bit
worried because as we've talked about
for a couple weeks now this looks like a
two to three man draft class in terms of
that elite upper tier so you got six
teams right now trying to hope they get
into that upper tier because if you
start Owen for you are not making the
playoffs it's just a statistical like
impossibility so I think when you're
these six teams you're looking at 2020
already well I'm fascinated by this
group for a couple of different reasons
number one being five of these coaches
are in their first year with the team so
you would think they have somewhat of a
leash where if this is a disaster this
year which it's looking like it for many
they usually don't move on from him it
does happen we saw it where Arizona
recently but you would think the bengals
hired a very young coaching Zach Taylor
where they're gonna give him time to
build things the way he wants Denver
with Vic Fangio is interesting and Adam
GaSe with the Jets because you know
those were interesting hires this is in
cases first time as a head coach but
Donald being out might have a built-in
excuse for him we'll see what Joe
Douglas thinks of that I'm not fully
sold cases safe but there's a lot of
time left when Sam gets back
the Arizona obviously the cliff that was
always a risky hire it doesn't look
great but there's a lot of time left but
Washington I think Jay Gruden is already
fired I really do there's a clear
disconnect between him and ownership in
the front office I don't believe he ever
wanted to Wayne Haskins I think some of
the reactions we've seen today I think
me and you were very in the middle on
Dwayne Haskins we never saw him as this
elite quarterback prospect top five pick
we also didn't see him as this late day
2 guy that didn't have the he always had
the tools we were very in the middle on
Swain Haskins where he was somewhere in
the 20s for us and he ends up going you
know in the top half of the draft but
when it comes down to it this is not how
to do it right now and that kind of goes
towards the coach the blame yeah I think
it does and like you said there's a
disconnect there which that's Washington
that's just what they do this is the
most dysfunctional organization in the
NFL so of course
they're going to be dysfunctional when
it comes to making decisions I think Jay
Gruden seat is incredibly hot I mean
there were rumors that he would be fired
if they lost to the Giants which they
did and he hasn't been fired yet so I
think it's just a matter of time at this
point which I'm sure his brother will
hire him and everything will be okay but
another one that let's talk about the
Atlanta Falcons they have started very
poorly one-in-three go back to halftime
of the Super Bowl this team has been
terrible since Tom Brady came back on
them and I think we're Dan Quinn you
start to worry is the message stale
because you have talent you have Matt
Ryan you have Devon to Freeman you have
Julio Jones Calvin Ridley they've
stocked your defense with first-round
picks and you're still not getting the
job done so I look at Dan Quinn that
will be a very heavily sought after job
if and when he's fired because there are
a lot of playmakers and a lot of tools
there to work with and an owner that
people would like to play for because
he's a good owner he'll throw money at
you the facilities are good it's a big
market the Falcons job has a chance to
be very very interesting I do too and
I'm disappointed because I believed in
this team before the year I thought they
would legitimately be in the playoff
hunt and let's be real Matt since Kyle
Shanahan left that team has not been the
same it's as simple as that you have to
wonder it feels like so much of the
Super Bowl influence actually came from
Kyle Shanahan they've also had some bad
injury luck but I can't explain the lack
of involvement for Calvin Ridley over
these past couple weeks it's just not
great all around but when you look at
this number one number two number three
picots so fascinating because the
Dolphins and the Bengals and definitely
the Broncos they want to be in the
running for a guy like Toa and when you
look at the Jets Washington and the
Cardinals chase young or Jerry Judy
would be very nice pieces for both of
those teams right so at the end of the
day this race to be picking at the top
again I know some fans do not want to
hear it right now Jets fans want Sam
Donald back I totally understand Broncos
fans probably want to see Drew lock but
when it comes to it down to it at the
end of the day like you said those
premium picks always matter in the top
three to get a great player yeah
so in the Dolphins I I think we all
expected it would take to uh at number
one or wherever that is so you would
hope so
in the Bengals I think we're gonna see
them move on from Andy Dalton chase
young would look very very good there
even though they have added some guys in
the edge the Broncos have Von Miller and
Bradley Chubb it's now lost for the
season right fortunately but he's there
for the long term exactly and they
drafted drew Locke in the second last
year so if the Broncos end up with the
top three pick that could be a jerry
judy landing spot like we did a mock
draft Monday so it's gonna be
interesting to watch it all shake out
one quarter through the season the
number one pick race is heating up and
some hot seats are heating up as well
let's take a break we come back we're
gonna give you our Award winners from
the first quarter of the NFL season
let's hand out some a hardware Conor the
first quarter MVP this was actually hard
for me to decide on I went maybe a homer
pick I'm gonna give it to Pat mahomes
ten touchdowns no interceptions a
perfect for no team and they're doing it
without Eric Fisher at left tackle
without Tyreke Hill at wide receiver
without Damian Williams at running back
so the fact that my Holmes leads the NFL
in yards and touchdowns no interceptions
that one was big for me and therefore
and oh I think he's the league MVP right
now it's hard to argue with that one
Matt it really is I know the over/under
for him was said I think at 36 and a
half touchdowns this year it feels like
he's gonna go over that again or at
least you would hope so but if I was
gonna argue against it I'm taking
Russell Wilson Russell Wilson has
quietly been amazing this year
absolutely amazing eight touchdowns no
picks over 1,100 passing yards he added
another two touchdowns on the on the
ground so ten total touchdowns no
interceptions it's really amazing how
efficient russ is with the ball he's
never thrown more than 11 picks in a
season in his career and he's usually
under the mark of 10 so for us in
Seattle where he hasn't always had the
most help especially on the offensive
line he he's just quietly this top five
quarterback year after year and this
year I can realistically see him
finishing as a top two quarterback in
the NFL yeah I love Russ and a guy who's
never had a losing season and this
unbelievable Doug Baldwin they really
haven't they've gotten some you know
production out of decaf or 3-under
Greg Jennings or Gary Jennings was cut
then he wasn't cut rust has had a very
very good year how about Offensive
Rookie of the Year I know a lot of
people are gonna want us to say Daniel
Jones here I'm not James James exactly
come on do it yet not gonna do it how
about this one though Gardner Minshew he
has come in and lit a fire under the
Jacksonville Jaguar seven touchdowns one
interception he looks he looks like the
real deal he looks like he might you
know Tom Brady or Wally PIPP or whatever
analogy you want to use this deal and
end up the starter there Gardner Minshew
deserves a ton of credit he is my first
quarter Rookie of the Year yeah I went
with Terry McLaren from Washington when
you look at the fact that he has missed
the game because he was her I know that
sucks but the quarterback situation he's
playing with and he already has three
touchdowns over 250 yards receiving I
mean he could legitimately be a thousand
yard receiver as a rookie in the NFL a
double-digit touchdowns guy he does
everything we know how good of a special
teams player Terry is but he's being
asked to essentially be the number one
wide receiver on that team I love seeing
a receiver at the top of this offense of
Rookie of the Year hunt after the first
quarter of the year especially a player
like Terry that is in such a tough
situation in Washington hopefully when
Haskins does come in and looks a little
more comfortable those two get back in a
rhythm that we know they have yeah
absolutely it's gonna be fun watching
those two kind of grow together on the
job now how about Defensive Rookie of
the Year we haven't seen a lot of rookie
defenders really step up right now you
know in the secondary guys just haven't
made plays I went with someone who has
been I think underrated very very good
this year
chase Windham itch has three sacks
already this season he had a one and a
half against the Dolphins half a sack
against your Jets won against the bills
last weekend he has been very very good
for the New England Patriots not as a
full-time starter as well so those three
sacks I believe that is best among all
rookie defenders so our guy chased one
of its getting Rookie of the Year
consideration yeah it's a very strange
year for all the defensive rookies
Quintin Williams really hasn't played
much at all he's expected to be back
this week and then obviously I thought
ed Oliver has been pretty good but
there's nobody
really leading the pack in stats I went
with someone who I thought had his best
game of the year this week on Monday
Night Football and that's Devin Busch
from the Steelers this was the juicy pic
before the season Devin White's been
hurt so we just haven't gotten a seal
out of these guys but I thought Devin
Busch looked like the player as
advertised against the Bengals on Monday
night which was good to finally see
because I thought he was a little bit
slow to start very slow start all right
how about first quarter coach of the
year I'm gonna get called out for this
but I don't care I'm taking Kyle
Shanahan the Niners are three you know
they had to buy in week four no one
expected this team to start three you
know I definitely did not they've
overcome a lot of injuries to get to
this point as well Jimmy Garoppolo is
playing fantastic you have Matt Breda
and Raheem monster in the backfield
instead of Tevin Coleman instead of
Jerick McKinnon they're just playing
exceptionally well right now and I know
they're gonna be people say well they
haven't played anyone it's the only
undefeated team in the NFC right now
they have a pretty good foothold on win
in the West without a doubt I don't
think this is the most talented team in
the end I've seen Kyle Shanahan gets the
most out of this team they played very
well Jimmy G's played well I think we've
seen Nick Bosa really turned it on so
and like you said Matt that running game
with Shanahan is so impressive so he
definitely deserves those honors I'm
going on the AFC side of things I think
Shawn McDermott has done a really nice
job with this Bills team now they were
one mediocre Josh on performance away
from beating the Patriots and leading
the AFC East with the perfect record but
Josh really struggled in this one
McDermott I think is coaching possibly
the best defense in the NFL right now
it's either them or the Bears and
obviously in separate conferences so
lovely start for the bills I think
McDermott deserves a lot of praise yeah
he absolutely does I actually almost put
him on my list they've been that good
how about the surprise team of the year
I'm gonna go back to the 49ers I really
thought this was like an eight and eight
team I think that's where I had them in
our preseason preview so I did not
expect this three you know start now
they do have to finish that is the key
but this this hot start that they've
come out on and I and again they had the
week four by so they're not they're not
right at the forefront for a lot of
people when you think of the best teams
but three no start really really good
for John Lynch and Kyle Shanahan
it's definitely
has been I'm going with the team that I
feel very wrong about right now and
that's the Detroit Lions and I know
they're 2 1 & 1 which might not you know
obviously scream wow so surprising but
look at the games that they've played
and they beat the Chargers they beat the
Eagles on the road that is no easy task
and they took the Chiefs right down to
the wire now I think the tie against
Arizona will be looked back at a
disappointing game that they probably
should have won but I didn't think the
Lions would be contending in the NFC and
so far they look like a team that plans
to stick around they do man they look
they look good Matt Patricia I don't
know if it's you chalk it up to the
culture change or what their but they
look good biggest surprise as a player
Shaq Barrett left the Denver Broncos he
wanted to be a full-time starter really
no one was in on this guy he said it's a
one-year deal with the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers and he now has nine sacks
leading the NFL ocula this man is going
to be paid this offseason good for Shaq
Barrett undrafted out of Colorado State
right now he has more sacks than the
Denver Broncos do so looks like they
made it letting him go yeah x-man yeah I
said good for Shaq because he was kind
of lost in that fridge at market and I
don't understand why I thought it's a
rotational player in Denver he really
flash and Todd Bowles is getting the
most out of him down there and he is
about to get a huge deal at the end of
this year 20 sacks completely in sight
for Shaq Barrett I'm going on the
offensive side of the ball
Austin Eckler you can't bench this guy
even though Melvin Gordon's back Eckler
is such a good receiving back
he has six total touchdowns he's been
efficient on the ground like I said he's
been phenomenal as a pass catcher I love
what Austin hecklers done and if you
watch the Chargers when Melvin Gordon
was hurt you're not surprised by this
but now that Melvin Gordon's back it
only aids their ground game they can
really give him touches especially in
the red zone but Eckler you can't lose
time away from the field for this guy
because he has been phenomenal yeah he
has been good like you said whether it's
fantasy football or real football
the Chargers got to find a way to keep
this guy a big part of what they're
doing offensively out there in LA so
those are our first quarter Award
winners let us know who yours are tweet
us at stick to football or leave it in
your iTunes review we'll be sure to see
it let's take
can we come back we have the greatest
wide receiver to ever catch a football
Jerry Rice alright stinkies you know I'm
excited today as the resident 49ers fan
here we have the goat Jerry Rice joining
us Jerry thanks for taking some time man
I tell us you are doing something with
pasta Roni which is why we get some time
with a Hall of Famer and the greatest
receiver of all time yeah we both are
San Francisco treats right that's right
it's good way to put it yeah you know I
have partners with rice aronia but I
thought about changing my name to rice
pasta Roni think about that that that
would be real cool right would you
actually do it Jerry I'm challenging you
the reason why I'm thinking about is you
know with tailgating and with football
going on and I like to think of my step
out as having that MVP status and all of
that in and I have come to the
conclusion that when you think about
tailgating it's a little bit more
difficult than you know catching a pass
running that perfect route you know it's
going to touchdown or something like
that but what I like is you know with
pasta Roni and rice-a-roni the varieties
they're so many and to choose from and
you know I have always had some go to
plays back in the day when I was on the
football field if I was you know wanted
to run that post route that corner route
score a touchdown or something like that
and when it comes to tailgating it's all
about jalapeno cheddar that's it because
I was spicy on the football field so
that's one of one of the reason why I
have teamed up with rice-a-roni well
speaking of spicy I think one of the
hottest debates in the NFL right now is
especially without Antonio Brown playing
who the best wide receiver in today's
NFL is and who do you think that is
right now Jerry I think it's still Jerry
Rice you know from Julio Jones to Odell
Beckham
you know Antonio Brown God you know but
I would have to say I would say Julio
Jones because the size of this guy what
he brings to the game is around running
his speed his physicality off the
football so I would give him overall
number one Jerry when you watch the NFL
today is with the way DBS have to play
in your prime how many catches would you
have in today's level
well you guys putting me on the spot
right now right we are yeah it's a whole
different ballgame now and you know
players are more protected there it's
not really that much bump and run and
you're able to you know just be
explosive off the line of scrimmage you
don't have to worry about linebackers
trying to take your head off going
across the middle anymore so how many
passes would I catch like 200 is where I
was going with that you know I'm a very
modest guy yeah but probably you know
with the league and the way the game is
going now I was I would say probably
over a hundred catches per season well
we know you played for a really long
time probably could have played forever
if you wanted to and now we're watching
Tom Brady Drew Brees Frank Gore they're
the next in line of guys that are
playing so long do you think that gets
underappreciated sometimes by fans god
you know I think no I think it's left up
to the player yeah you know I'm sure the
fans they appreciate the players you
know Frank Gore I think he's number four
on the list now has a running back up
with 15,000 yards you know Larry
Fitzgerald he's number two right now
right behind me so you know you got to
love the game and you got to continue to
work hard and you're probably gonna see
a lot of players you know play longer
now because
you know the game is not as well these
players are being taken care of now more
than back in the day so they're being
protected and when I played it was
totally different
so you might see these guys you know
play for more like 16 years or even 20
years
you mentioned Larry Fitzgerald you ever
look at that and think gosh he's like
see like 200 catches behind you do you
ever get a little nervous thinking that
if he goes off for a couple years he
might start to get close to those about
six what would you have 15:49 catches so
he's at least within that stratosphere
no one else has really got that close
before yeah I think he's about 224 I
know exactly where he's at but you know
if married if he should break my record
or something like that I would be the
first one to congratulate him because I
know what this guy's all about his work
ethic what he brings to the game how he
passes the knowledge on to the players
and you know he's just like he's a great
ambassador for the NFL so I had the
opportunity to spend some time with him
this past weekend when he broke Tony
Gonzalez you know receiving record to
get into that second spot in and this
guy he hit it right on the nose because
he said you know what there was no
celebration in being second so you know
like I said if he's if he's the one to
to come close to it or break my record
I'll be the you know first one to
congratulate him playing with a lot of
different quarterbacks throughout your
career obviously some great ones was
there anyone in particular that you had
the best relationship with you know I
would say Montana okay I mean I just
knew this guy in and out the chemistry
that we had on the football field I
could look at him and I knew exactly
what he
thinking but then after joel FB and i
was able to build that relationship with
uh Steve Young and it's all through
repetition you know how you practice is
how you're gonna play on that Sunday or
that Monday are you know doing playoffs
are Super Bowls and stuff like that so
it's all about the preparation that goes
into it I I can remember being I was
pretty young when when the Niners made
that move but I remember hearing that it
was an adjustment for you and the other
receivers going from Montana who was a
righty - Steve who was a lefty it was
that accurate was that a thing that like
you guys had to adjust to you know a
different spin on the ball and a
different look of it coming out of his
hand yeah it was very difficult very
difficult and I used to have ten ball
she was one of the equipment guys he was
the lefty he would just throw me balls
and because the ball is bent differently
and you know Steve was more of a running
quarterback when he first came into the
league anyone to become more of a pocket
passer and we were able to go on to do
great things you know because of the way
we practice and the way we prepared you
know doing the week
wowthat's yeah that is a long adjustment
was there any point where you felt a
breakthrough or was it just like one
quick offseason and you got used to it
how long does that take you know what
god it's just that you know it's just
you got to have a guy that's gonna throw
you a lot of balls and hit higher Don
even I yeah yes even I we used to have
to practice we would get together and we
would just you know throw the ball
around work on certain routes and stuff
like that then it became natural what we
could just go out and just cut loose and
have fun now I do have to ask because
like like I've been saying huge Niners
fan here and I will never forget your
last game as a Niner now that time has
passed what are your feelings about that
day I mean obviously you know tio has
the huge day and it it wasn't the
send-off the 49er fans expected I don't
know that it was the send-off you
expected now you know here we are you
know 15
years later is that Dave one that you
can look back on fondly not really no
because I thought I would play forever
with the San Francisco 49ers and that's
something that I wanted to do but
everything comes to an end and you know
that was my final game and I remember
giving the ball to Terrell Owens I think
he had how many catches about 20 me yeah
about 20 catches so no it was uh it was
t oday not Jerry Rice but it was great
you know playing in San Francisco for so
many years I feel like we have some of
the greatest fans ever and I wanted to
have a big day on that day but it was no
way that opposing team was gonna let me
do that
well Jerry thank you so much for joining
us and thanks to rice and pasta Ronnie
forgiven us time with you we really
really appreciate it all right for more
info you can go to go team right comm ok
guys thanks thanks so much
Jerry thanks to getting to Jerry Rice
this Conor and I were talking off air
that said the second time I've had an
opportunity to talk to him and it's like
I don't get like those family moments
anymore but that's a big one rice is a
pretty big one for me yeah it was cool
and I like how honest Jerry was about a
lot of different things especially an
interesting question like his last game
is a Niner but more so that he feels
Julio's the best receiver in the NFL and
I know a lot of people feel you know
Hopkins is in there as well and it's
hard to pick between them both but you
have to wonder and Matt Ryan's great but
you have to wonder what like Julio would
have done we say this about every great
quarterback but you sometimes just
wonder what Julio would do with a great
quarterback now don't get on Tom Brady
that's Aaron Rodgers is the perfect
quarterback for him
so a big thanks you know to Jerry for
joining us and it's time for draft on
draft we're not missing it we're not
forgetting about you and this guy never
forgets about us that's Patrick
Chamberlain if you had to rank the
rookie quarterbacks based purely on
their NFL performances to this point how
would you rank them mr. Giants fan here
just trying to get someone for Daniel
Jones
I understand what you're doing here
that's all right i-i'll go back to where
I ranked them for Rookie of the Year
I think Gardner Minshew has been the
best I would say Daniel Jones would be
second
I think Kyler Murray by default is third
you ain't Haskins I'm sorry has to be
fourth I'm not gonna include Jared
Stidham he threw three passes one did
get picked but that was just mop-up duty
so I think of the rookies Haskins has
been in again half a game you know what
I'm say F but three picks and half a
games really bad and you just hopefully
he can shake that off we don't want to
see another situation where a guy's
confidence just gets Nathan Peterman
here so hopefully he'll bounce back next
week
yeah hard to disagree there Gardner has
just been really unbelievable and I
think Daniel Jones had the best
individual performance the game against
the Bucks was phenomenal he really came
back down to earth against Washington
and didn't have a bad game it's just we
saw the two picks and you know he had
some good drives it was just a very very
average game against a bad team so
that's why he and he needs more time
maybe he'll finish as the top guy who
knows but I agree with your rankings
there Matt hearted hard to disagree yeah
all right let's move on next one James
Green asked do you think the change in
law in California allowing
student-athletes to profit from their
image rights will force the NCAA to make
changes to student-athlete rights or
will they be just as stubborn as always
I think we're already seeing this even
Tuesday morning as we are recording the
NCAA is being stubborn now Florida is
maybe gonna pass a bill similar to what
they're doing in California I think
other states will follow suit the
n-c-double-a you can see the talking
points being distributed to people like
oh man how will North Texas afford to
pay players like the University of Texas
they won't the colleges are not paying
the [ __ ] players people
I'm so tired just reading Joe Meaux on
Twitter being like well there's a
competitive disadvantage now you think
there isn't right now hey Ohio State
Clemson Alabama LSU and who have throw
Texas or Michigan they are Georgia best
players in the country every year are
the best teams I know it's ridiculous
it's absolutely ridiculous I think
people are looking for reasons to shoot
this down
it's gonna be fine I think people should
have the freedom to make money off of
their likeness and if you have a problem
with that
we probably disagree on a lot of things
in life so that's all I can leave it at
it's just it's ridiculous to think this
is gonna drastically change the
competitive balance because guess what
that balance does not exist
there's no parity in college football
there's no such thing all right Todd
Rice asked if the Bengals end up with
the number one pick in take to a do the
Dolphins settle for just like Herbert
it's hard to believe they would tank
this hard for him yeah well that's not
what you want to hear no I think Jace
young and get a gas back next year
I agree build a football team don't just
take a quarterback and guess what you'll
probably still be bad enough to get
Trevor Lawrence or just in the fields
they open spades you guys did this in
the Ryan Tannehill draft you backed
yourself into a corner where you had to
take a quarterback and you got a really
bad one because of it so just like
Connor said build a football team take
the best players available you might
walk out of this thing with Chase young
and Jerry Judi you know and then next
year okay get Justin fields you get
Trevor Lawrence don't just take someone
to take someone I think that's the worst
move that this team can make iced tea
music I love this question in the spirit
of spite and anger let's kick people out
of the Hall of Fame all right let's do
it
I have two immediate emiram guys Jerome
Bettis and Tony Dungy get out gone yeah
I agree I definitely agree I need to
like go through though and find more
there's the Bettis is such a tough one
and I know we do this act at least once
a year and I'm sure Steeler fans hate it
and I'm sorry I just think it's a tough
sell man
didn't you average under four yards of
carry purse career yeah that's the one
three more is gonna be disrespectful
that's my fear when we start doing this
yeah III will say I've always obviously
adding it to watch a play I've always
heard Lynn Swann didn't really deserve
to be in there it was more like he had
that one
really good play same with John
Stallworth again I'm not trying to just
piss off Steeler fans but that's what
you've always I've always heard like
they maybe don't actually belong in
there because the numbers weren't great
but they did make some of the biggest
moments in NFL history so if you want to
go off that they should I don't know
about Bob Griese I think he's in just
because the undefeated team also and I'm
glad you're not sitting beside me when I
say this I don't think Joe Namath
deserves to be there I think he's a
moment sky like he just said right it's
like oh he wore a fur coat and he got a
ton of ass and he played quarterback he
wasn't that good of a quarterback I mean
the greatest yet of all time is Darrelle
Revis so like the best football player
is Darrelle Revis for what he did at
corner to change the position so I was
like Curtis Martin a second yes I would
agree with that too it's very close
between the rebus and Curtis Mart I love
Joe Namath but yeah it's I mean you get
into the numbers like this goes back to
why Eli Manning should not be getting
into the Hall of Fame right but he will
he was a moment's absolute - tag Tommy
asked as prospects what would you rank
Derwin James Jamal Adams Minka
Fitzpatrick and grant Dell Pitt this is
tough because you have to eliminate
hindsight completely so I would say
Jamal
yeah Minka Derwin and Delpit would be my
order I loved Jamal and the cool thing
is like where you have actual number
grades you can go back and compare guys
pretty easily I actually really liked
Minka - I liked him better than German
James Irwin was coming off an injury at
Florida State his last year there he
didn't quite look like himself that was
a big concern for me dope it has just
not looked that good this year yeah I
need to
I know Jamal was the highest from me out
of all four of them and that's not
because the Jets drafted him before that
draft he was my number two overall
player in that class now I think I ended
up having Derwin above minka and as it
stands right now Delpit would be the
fourth out of all of them and you know
how much I loved lb before the season
but those other three guys were special
players and they are special players in
the NFL Jamal might be a top two safety
in the NFL when durman's healthy looks
like the best safety in football
at times right so and make I mean just
got traded for a first-round pick make
us a good football player so absolutely
that's it that's how it would go for me
Jamaal Derwin minka Delpit Delpit has
time to make up ground but it's got to
start making some more plays yup so last
question from Connor Leahy with Georgia
having three big time quarterback
prospects the last three years so B
Jacob Eason Jake from Justin fields did
they keep the worst one or does their
system undersell quarterbacks i think
they kept the least naturally talented
one but they might have kept the the
smartest like Fromm's yeah well like he
was really really good he's good for
their system I will say I don't think
Kirby smarts offense is asking the
things that Justin Fields is asked to do
at Ohio State or he's not taking the
chances the East and gets at Washington
but they win a ton of football games so
it's hard to argue with what they're
doing yeah I mean I think when I look at
it it worked out for everyone right
that's how I look at it where Georgia's
win a lot of football games Jake from
there is executing the offense and
they're confident that he can win them a
national title this year we'll see
I picked Georgia to win the SEC so I
can't sit here and say they [ __ ] it up
because I think they're that good I just
saw Jacob Eason play this weekend that
arm is as real as it gets
he has some things to clean up in his
game where I don't think George is
sitting there and going how do we let
this guy get away right now
Justin fields I love Justin fields I
thought he should have never went to
Georgia because I knew this would happen
that he would not win that job from a
guy that already had taken it from
someone and locked it in
I thought fields frosh now it worked out
cuz fields I think his could win a
Heisman with a bio state if not this
year next year and Ryan day is the
perfect football coach for a Justin
field so we don't say this often a lot
in the football world everybody won they
really did it's like when a trade works
for everyone it doesn't have it very
often but what it does is good and it's
pretty fun watching those three guys I'm
all in on Justin fields as well all
right that is our show we will be back
Friday morning getting you ready for the
weekend and don't forget Melo and I will
be at Arrowhead this weekend
Colts at Chiefs for Sunday Night
Football we will be a lot Jay at 3:00
p.m.
tailgating recording the podcast so come
say hi get a free kuzey I've heard they
ordered us a keg of natty light for this
tailgate so Wow no you're you're
ditching Boulevard well I think we'll
get both because okay right I'm not good
I mean if we're in Kansas City I'm
drinking Boulevard I was gonna say
that'd be sinful for music cake and
natty cost like $20 probably like 1250
right right it's it's not much so that's
probably why we got it all right for
Conners Matt will talk to you all Friday
morning